[Music]
hey guys did you know that we have a
podcast you can actually check it out in
our description box below and please
please please when you check it out rate
it five stars not one not two not three
not four five hey you're back I am yeah
where the [ __ ] have you been
yeah puta sometimes I've been behind
cameras here is it go anywhere for over
the break I went up to Newark Howell to
visit my brother and my sister-in-law
just like another married yeah and the
are married now
you have another sister yes but in a way
which brother my older brother she has
she only has one brother
no but the sister also identified as a
brother brother you're talking about you
have a sister anymore
is your sister a brother or is your
sister a lesbian no is your sister a
brother this is no problem okay so you
always confusing me Julia with the
family all right so I have a brother who
is five years older than me he
identifies as a brother though you all I
mean he's a brother a brother
I'm so [ __ ] confused who is a black
man I have my so I've been I have my
sister [ __ ] man okay a brother a brother
yes I haven't brought five years older
five years old as a brother yes and then
I have a sister that's that's two and a
half years old got it older than me but
but over time has identified differently
with her gender so now she feels more
towards the masculine non-binary side
meaning that like she prefers the
pronouns he or this so you got two
brothers then and your middle brother
yeah
you had her your brother then no I mean
who you don't climb a biker Pro down I
don't call I don't call him my brother I
called him my sibling because that's
what he requested that's dope
are you requested right or and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter he who
are they so you got us you don't have a
sister anymore no but you got a newt
that's what I'm trying to say that you
got a new sister
I do cuz you're a brother your first
brother's wife yes is your new sister my
sister-in-law that's awesome I'm so
confused man I'm still trying to figure
out what the black guys coming from yeah
he does oh cool my brother identifies as
a man my brother identifies as a man but
I call him a her why just that's what
brothers do good night younger brothers
young good the brothers can't see [ __ ]
like that to them all the time
you got a taco [ __ ] - [ __ ] survive in
his world you know I noticed that Asian
parents like there's a few of them that
would actually use the wrong pronouns so
like if they know it's so like I hear my
dad call my brother she sometimes
they're stupid no it's just they get
confused cuz I think I don't think he
really thinks that they're stupid no
they're not well they got stupid mouth
no but I guess she was saying that in
Cantonese there's not really
differentiating like he should hear
something right oh yeah I mean it's what
a whack-ass language I mean there's like
certain words that can give off like the
pro none of the person language yeah how
did the pronunciation but in the writing
there is though yeah yeah that's how
much age people could give a [ __ ] less
what you are right you work on you down
work that's it hate and a day though I
don't care [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah identify
with a job or not
you identify with a paycheck
yeah [ __ ] there's [ __ ] burrito
what Purina there you go yeah dude so
you just been learn San Francisco oh
yeah I want an export there's a really
good fried chicken place up there
what is it let's just go got some
bomb-ass food oh man is it really
every time we've been up there we Yelp
some [ __ ] we've been highly disciplined
it's always one start off at least when
we win it fits like a four star that's a
la 3 star mmm when we win but things
could have caught up yeah yeah la is
pretty pretty up there though man cuz I
you know a lot of places that are 5
stars in other states don't even compare
to any restaurants here yeah 2 star 3
star we're spoiled out here man that's
why I can't leave San Diego has great
restaurants - why like if the food is
wet where would you go
I think I just go to Hawaii or I'll go
to Texas or I'll go to somewhere else
where there's a lot of land I want a lot
of man why you wanna go there cuz I like
it there
are we talking about Tokyo yeah okay I
probably lose yeah you know they don't
like Chinese people right they're like
they're like the kay-kay they're like
the nicest KKK so what they want is
people to come visit but they don't want
people to overstay their welcome yeah
why you think the whole country's like
95% Japanese and it's hard as [ __ ] to
get citizenship I went to Japan like in
college with my friend and we were
exploring and her relatives didn't think
that I was even Chinese at all I know
it's I mean they didn't hear you
freaking talk or like didn't see you
later on the bottom put it this way I'm
Japanese they don't think I'm Japanese
and I don't want to live there you don't
want to live there trust me you don't
want to live that you don't want to be
there you hear it depends only fun to
travel but just to live because it's
really lonely when you're there my mom
been living there and she tells me all
the same [ __ ] just come over here to
travel don't [ __ ] him my brother went
went and he worked there for a minute
and he's all like man I can't make no
friends man people are [ __ ] fake as
[ __ ] like you
you have your clique right you have your
group since like high school whatever
and that's it you stick with that group
you don't really make new friends and if
you do they're weirdos yeah no new
friends you just have lifetime friends
out there but you start small and you
can get in with the group or whatever
but it takes a long time like it takes
way longer than out here are the Yakuza
pretty accepting I think that one's kind
of cool because you know it's it's like
got a fine friends of you the process is
more legit you know at least you know
what you're getting yourself into when
these real people like you don't know if
they like you or not gonna join these
[ __ ] how about your fingers we
good yeah you'll be my friend chop thank
you I mean it's clear like Yakuza is
like go rob this [ __ ] go kill
this guy and then you're cool it's like
well thank you for making it so easy now
so you're pretty cool a lot of like
those are natural disasters they like
hook up the whole city they bring food
water all that stuff I thought they just
bury bodies there so now then why is
everyone so like scared of tattoos I'm
sure that loose they just got scary eyes
it's scary let's couldn't go into the
one sense because your tech I kept call
it even uh not gems either yeah II
brought unyoke I found a CrossFit that
was round by Reebok and I was like cool
this is an American company and then I
called them and then they're like yeah
no tattoos sorry and I'm like you guys
are [ __ ] Reebok showing your tattoo
is like a [ __ ] wearing blue from head to
toe walking around the street and
representing that's why
see that's why I never got tattoos
that's all the time you spend in Japan
yeah because I always wanted to go to an
onsen and that's why I didn't get you
didn't go to own zones but here listen
let me just tell my story yeah you never
seen our dicks we never been a we spawn
[ __ ] dick check each other I saw
everybody's dead we bake gazing together
what is going on right now man why well
find another spot you [ __ ] don't like
I just don't like Korean saunas with the
whole scrubbing thing I don't like that
yeah we don't have to scrub each other
we never do that's all cases dick I
[Music]
don't want to see your dick directly I
want to peripherally see your dick I've
seen everybody's Nick I mean not the
guys the guys I saw David choice Nick
did Oh what's going on in Jake head
right now dude that's not cases big
[ __ ] tied it into a bow just [ __ ]
dangle them around to break not very
long Nick's not very long no he's a
grower not a shower its way Joe what do
you know you've never seen it because
I'm trying to bat my homie oh you think
a [ __ ] dick you know say you want me to
tell the truth then no so you what's a
San Francisco Julia they got big dicks
over there San Francisco so funny
because you could smell Chinatown from a
mile away there it's why does every
Chinatown smell the same no matter where
you are in the world [ __ ] smells like
the inside of a duck's butthole dude it
smells like fish sewer and cigarettes
and incense a bump it bump it's a
[ __ ] cat [ __ ] too yeah you know is
weird when we stayed there recently
it felt we're trying to tell no we in
San Francisco when we went with Casey's
brother oh they did an area where it was
not really near Chinatown but everywhere
around us was a lot of Chinese stuff and
we're like waited this trying to tell
them like is this another attempt
almost all of San Francisco's Chinatown
meet you yeah so that's I'm saying like
it feels like the whole place Chinese
were the original San Francisco Mexicans
it was like hella populated Dale San
Francisco yeah on laundromats is [ __ ]
did not like they litter there were the
construction guys that's why everything
broke during the earthquake
so what the [ __ ] sorry man you just want
it done quick we right do this I want to
go to I haven't been in so long I used
to go like every year cuz my uncle lived
out there but not any mom
the weather's really nice it's actually
really cools like 60 summertime is the
best time they go to San Francisco
I remember freezing my balls off does
anyone ever burn the water up there yeah
dude no cuz it's so cold every day those
were wetsuits or whatever yeah they'll
go up there they'll die it's all good I
never [ __ ] swam up there - it looked
too treacherous that's where Alcatraz is
I kind of want to swim in Alcatraz why
the [ __ ] do you hate your mother sharks
that's why they built out we'll be had
it there cuz there's shark infested it's
himself like he tries to do so much [ __ ]
to [ __ ] himself over like I just want to
be in a hammock and [ __ ] swing sad
side but I like I like pushing myself
and like testing like I heard Nick Diaz
on that three times I'm like maybe I
should try it one time you are not Nick
Diaz I know he's a professional fighter
you have multiple businesses maybe
somewhere shorter you know what we swam
through that one place in Hawaii that's
all pretty fun yeah Julia came with us I
felt like accomplishment didn't last the
next time - an accomplished mirror I
like when you reach the other side
you're like damn that was done is
getting in and out of a [ __ ] hammock
bar become so successful he challenges
himself yo all in the same circle
turning into a hammock while you're
trying to relax hard right yeah I'm
saying dude I want to swim to the island
and come back and then reward myself
with the hammock or another one is when
you rub coconut oil all over your body
and they're sad
and then you touch you're like oh man
and you try to take that off and then it
gets on the other side whoa we're just
going to the water and get the sand
awesome Wow Julia it's a joke listen
every time I'm in Hawaii I struggle just
to stay alive so I'm pretty [ __ ] good
all right I know I can't even stick my
head up a car window with us match my
teeth and do it so I'm pretty fine all
right where's the excitement in life
this diamond is that I get to have my
teeth - I just thought yourself watch my
old wife whoa I forgot that I had a
surfboard smashed in my face what are
the odds like I fall and my surfboard
goes directly as I was falling I was
like whoa
and I see your face design it covers
your face and I dive in the water I get
out and then you have [ __ ] blood and
I'm like turtle yeah oh yeah there's a
turtle right off he goes this look oh
[ __ ]
turtle no [ __ ] my face you ask you what
the funniest part of that I didn't put
in the video cuz I saw I saw the I was
watching the clips yesterday this is my
hard drive [ __ ] funny so I thought I
hit the face all you hear in the water
the GoPros is I felt so bad dude there
was so much [ __ ] ball no cuz you have
nice straight teeth right they're white
but they was all covered in blood no eat
somewhere and then you stabbed yourself
with the fork and oh it was just it was
it it was worse than that was a strong
yeah right with this rod in the nose oh
no another trip every time I went to
Hawaii hurt myself no so so good
every day you maybe you shouldn't go
anymore oh I just hurt myself in general
my life dude that's true you know why it
happens to you yeah karma dude no I'm a
good person well look at those [ __ ]
socks that shit's offensive show them
your [ __ ] socks I'm so offended
spread that [ __ ] that looks like gloves
this clothes so I wear Vibrams now when
I train with I so yeah and so it feels
good in your [ __ ] element yep I did
see how David set himself up so we went
camping and so there's that bonfire
metal thing right he built a fire with
with Sparks and stuff and I'm like props
to you that's dope that you built the
fire and then we need to set the extra
firewood and he leans it against the
metal thing and I'm like oh if I wasn't
here by morning all the [ __ ] fire
would have traveled through your tent
you would had a giant bonfire in her
tent what I've melted not like Dave you
need three feet of distance between the
[ __ ] firewood and where the fire is
everybody shut the [ __ ] up
first of all before we were two went to
sleep I want to put that water out on
the [ __ ] thing you know I'm saying
second of all I was not a Boy Scout
third of all oh whoa okay all right it
is what it is okay that's high set
himself up apparently you don't know
you're supposed to pre warm your wood
before you throw to the fire am i right
am i right
you if you have dangerous Bart telling
you that you should be careful that's a
big hazard I was like why the [ __ ] is
the dynamite right he was like hey did
you guys ever try to get the fire out of
the bonfire and we're like what and then
he goes yeah you're supposed to put a
trail like a wood and if you cut like
travels outside what the [ __ ] are you
talking words so if we're like look if
we're gonna build a little trail of fire
that's gonna leave the bonfire to
somewhere else at least we're all paying
attention we're all chilling there's a
fire so nice also he walks up to the
fire I think he's about to add more wood
to the fire he farts right into the
flames don't you [ __ ] judge me dude
did it burn it ass hairs are not
flammable yeah it smells like a perm
though so I just let you know it's about
like Dookie and perm
Wow their little cloud like in the
cartoons no not this time you think did
you ever melt the bottom of it let's
talk about this - it's [ __ ]
summertime right this pool goes he comes
out he goes so I didn't make a
reservation I said you didn't make a
[ __ ] reservation at a campsite that's
what I said okay
it's still safe I don't set myself up to
get surfboards in my mouth you gotta go
to another place well do you think I've
got to spend a night there yeah it was
good man there was no vacancies for like
the second day or something for the
second day but then they're all you're
lucky we have one spot for you tonight
like six
but they were like oh we have our six
boss but you got to leave tomorrow by
twelve yeah they're all six one night
spots so I have to leave the next day
if Robbie took this longer to pack all
of Tigers [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] to [ __ ]
get there but it was still cool cuz
knowing her out in nature and the Sun
wakes you up so we all woke up at like
five or six so even though we have to
leave by 12:00 we had a good like whole
day that we're still hanging out on to
making breakfast and all that that's
cool well how about well how was your
Grand Canyon RV trip cuz I've never
talked about that on here that was
pretty tight yeah it was really cool I
wish we could all gone um I mean the
group that we went with obviously our
friends and there was a lot of fun um
but yeah I want to do it again and I
want to do it with you guys
Cammie and I was like so jealous I'm
like how beautiful and take a look while
you're in [ __ ] Croatia Austria yeah
truffle hunting yeah I'm so jealous I'm
just [ __ ] hunting truffles you know
who else goes truffle hunting
slave-owners so just simply to put it
out there yeah in your face I didn't
know truffles looked like [ __ ] cancer
balls
yeah they call them smelly potatoes and
they first found in ministry oh yeah
when you show me those truffles and look
like [ __ ] smoker lungs yeah it's
pretty funny if you don't currently
they'll be growing through places on the
earth in that true history on Italy and
organ organ huh that's a lot of dope
places like I mean things that they grow
there that so for example like wasabi
laid golden organ - real wasabi for
that's cool they have I've been there
like twice you know it's one of the
dopest things about our RV when it's
going into really scenic area and you're
in the back of master bedroom of it and
you're laying on the master bedroom bed
and you see like the mountains and all
that you're just laying there while
someone else is driving you're like man
this is time until you start shaking
enough you're like [ __ ] I'm getting
carsick
I miss RV trips yeah it was a lot of fun
I want to do it again
who's driving of me and the Dean would
take turns cuz Anna Dean would get so
nervous cuz you know how he likes to
make eye contact when he's driving and
you you hear the hole where it's not
paying attention I think I need to drive
maybe getting to drive yeah and it
doesn't correct this fast you're looking
this way and you [ __ ] and you go like
this right
but because the RV is [ __ ] like 30
feet long so if you [ __ ] up even one
inch and you turn back the whole thing
keeps swinging it out and then it comes
back in so it's like you need a
different license for the RV no actually
oh you just do it the regular drivers
license but it's crazy one like a big
semi truck rolls by and then you can
just feel it like slam into you can't we
do film taking news in an RV yeah we
just never be an RV ever what's the part
it is pretty fun okay we gotta have
someone else drive this guy doesn't know
how to drive just a regular car catch
you next time no you like to make eye
contact member I just yelled at you like
two days ago cuz I'm like why you have
to look at my [ __ ] eyes look at that
Menke better you'll be driving the RV
and you're like I have to get this
[Laughter]
[Music]